[MUSIC PLAYING]
FLORIAN GSCHWANDTNER:
I think it's
necessary to push boundaries
to really change the rules
and change the game.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I grew up on a farm.
It was a very cool
childhood, because you're
growing up next to your
dad, working on the field.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
One thing what I
really learned about
was what does work all
day long actually mean?
I think as a farmer, you're
kind of an entrepreneur.
And this is where
for me, my heart
to become an entrepeneur
somehow started.
I decided to study
mobile computing,
where I met my co-founders.
I was running more often.
And then we said, hey, we have
to do something in that area.
We want to help people
change their life.
And I think being
physically fit really
supports whatever you're doing.
So we quit our jobs, and
we started Runtastic.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NINETTE GIARDINA:
There's something
about running that
connects you with somebody.
So when it's your own
daughter, it was on for me.
You want to keep going?
ALEXIS GIARDINA: Yeah, we can.
NINETTE GIARDINA: I was 40 years
old when I started running,
and it all started
with a challenge.
I signed my daughter
up for a 10k.
She was very upset
with me, so I told her
that I would run a 5k
to show her my support.
She said, like you're going to
get off the couch and run a 5k?
And I took the challenge,
and I ran the whole 5k.
ALEXIS GIARDINA:
The first marathon
she ran was the
one in Nashville.
NINETTE GIARDINA: I
used the Runtastic
How to Run a Marathon in 3 Hours
and 30 Minutes, and it worked.
It was really fun when my
daughter was cheering me
on about every 30 minutes.
ALEXIS GIARDINA:
Keeping up with her,
seeing where she's at,
how far until she's done.
NINETTE GIARDINA: Since
I've started running,
I've been doing
all kinds of races.
I am currently training
for my second marathon.
What running has taught me is
that I can achieve so much.
ALEXIS GIARDINA: I feel very
proud to say, that's my mom!
That's my mom!
She's the reason
I'm still running.
Otherwise, I probably
would have quit.
NINETTE GIARDINA: Alexis started
looking up half-marathons.
I'm like, you pick any place
you want to go to, and we'll go.
That'll be our thing.
So we've got that that I
don't have with somebody else.
FLORIAN GSCHWANDTNER:
Our business
has evolved so much
over the past years,
and now having more
than 200 employees
and 220 million downloads.
But this is not all.
Now being part of
the Adidas family,
together, we want to
get to the next level.
It's incredible what is
possible through technology.
Google Play has been the
perfect partner for us.
With their
technology, they allow
us to iterate in a very
innovative and quick way.
This is exactly what
we need for our users
to build a perfect product.
And it helps a lot to
really push boundaries.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Just cool to see that people
really transform themselves.
People are able to do things
they couldn't have done years
before.
And this is the game-changer.
[MUSIC PLAYING]